Is that him?
It's either him or the buff guy on the paper towels rolls
I can do that with one bare hand.
hello!
Hi!
You are Clark Kent, right?
Can I help you?
welcome back, everyone it's Charlie, this
is going to be my crisis on infinite earths
episode 2 video obviously a whole bunch of Batman Superman stuff going on.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're new to the channel I'm doing Easteregg videos for all the crossover episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
We're doing a new round of the Flash Ring
giveaway to all you have to do is enter is
be subscriber and let me know how you think crisis is going to end careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it yet
obviously we'll do top 10 and Easter eggs
as we go along.
Starting with number 10 of the alternate waverider and legends of tomorrow From 1974.
The only reference I could think is the earth
74 is a reference from the legends of tomorrow
episode where they went back to 1974 to keep Richard Nixon from resigning his presidency.
There was a joke sara had about the main version of the legend saying that she told them that
they wouldn't have to do crossovers anymore. The joke about the legends not being in last year's
crossover mostly because the show didn't want to deal with the crossover but also they start
to get too many characters and it's hard to
service them all, so it's actually better
that you not include all the show sometimes.
we find that the AI of this ship, though,
instead of being a version of Gideon is actually
a version of Leonard the Lenny version of
Captain cold.
So even though Captain cold isn't on-screen they were able to bring back the actor to
record new dialogue for the crossover heatwave still has the romance novel that he tried
to write in the previous season.
He winds up reading it to Superboy baby Jon Kent later says is totally kid friendly kids
love it, love my romance novels.
He says all of their legends retired on that
earth but one of them died.
I think he's probably referencing Captain
Cold who died during legends of tomorrow season 1
but the number 9 the story of the seven
paragons they had this funny moment with the
monitor getting interrupted by the crying
of Superboy baby Jon Kent of the just keep
passing them down the line until he gets to
heatwave heatwave is the only one who can
quiet them down.
He spends the entire episode being babysitter, which seems appropriate for the heatwave character.
If you haven't seen the last couple of years
they been using him mostly for comedy on legends
of tomorrow he'll be doing more traditional
flash rogue stuff during crisis episode 3
tomorrow night.
We find out who most of the paragons are during this episode.
Remember the seven symbols that were on the chamber that Nash Wells accidentally opened,
freeing the anti-monitor.
They probably have something to do with locking him back up again Supergirl is the paragon
of hope.
Sara is the paragon of destiny Batwoman winds up being the paragon of courage.
I wasn't really happy with the way they handled that storyline we'll talk about that in the
second.
And the kingdom come Superman is the paragon of truth that means there are three other
paragons that we need to find.
I believe black lightning is supposed to be
one of the paragons, so I don't know if they
intend to reveal all of the paragons before
the big midseason break.
Lex Luthor also makes his appearance in this episode because there's so much Superman stuff
happening in the episode it makes is that
you would bring back Lex Luthor for some of
that.
Also important to note that Lyla starts hearing voices I'll explained what that twist is because
it's right out of the comic book crisis on
infinite earths, but the TV show is changing
how it goes down a little bit.
Number eight we meet Kevin Conroy's Batman of the future on earth 99 Gotham it's a Batman
beyond Easter egg because that TV show started in 1999, but this is them referencing the
continuity of those TV shows.
Obviously they throw in a whole bunch of other stuff too like kingdom come Batman, Batman
the dark Knight returns a bunch of Frank Miller a bunch of really post-apocalyptic darkest
versions of Batman.
almost the darkest timeline Batman if you
don't consider flashpoint Batman the darkest
timeline Batman.
He's wearing the exoskeleton from the kingdom come to support his broken body.
You can also take this as sort of an injustice easter egg.
With the way he has kryptonite built into
his armor.
When he is trying to figure out whether or
not Kate Kane is real and who she says she
is because his version died five years ago.
He says Clayface is a puddle of mud right
now, meaning that he's dead and he can mimic
other people and Jane Doe is locked up in
Arkham.
Jane Doe is a character from the Batman comics the can mimic other people.
mimic their voices but as you saw during the episode he's meant to be the Batman who has
lost all hope.
There are a whole bunch of other Easter eggs when they're in those Batman scenes though
that i'll talk about a second.
number 7 Superman, the musical RIP Superman so they go to earth 75, Metropolis, and everybody
was wondering who this version of Superman was because he didn't look exactly like Tyler
Hoechlin, but he is wearing a Superman suit that is basically Tyler Hoechlin's Superman
suit the symbol on the Cape is all wrong though, but they're basically going for the death
of Superman from the comics it's ripped right out of the comic book panel instead of having
doomsday do the deed is Lex Luthor with the book of destiny trying to run around the multiverse
getting rid of every single version of Superman because they're on earth 75 though that's
an Easter egg for the 1975 Superman musical.
It was a Broadway musical that is the campiest thing that you've ever seen.
If you think there's a lot of camp during
the 70s Christopher Reeve Superman movies.
Superman the musical from 1975 takes that and goes way above and beyond.
So that's who This version of Superman is
meant to be, the Superman from that musical
but number 6 welcome back to Smallville.
so obviously he there's a lot to unpack here.
The reason why it's earth 167 is because that's an Easter egg for Superman comics number 167,
which is an issue of the classic series where Superman in Lex Luthor became a versions of
Batman and Superman except it was Clark Kent that became Batman and Lex Luthor that became
Superman.
people are thinking that this is a reference
to their friendship on the Smallville TV show
because Lex Luthor and Clark started out as friends before they became enemies and the
idea that Tom Welling said a long time ago
that he had always wanted to play Batman before
he played the Superman character.
So it's a really deep cut but if you wondered
why was 167 that's why it's a super meta-Easter
egg you see all the newspaper articles that
Lois Lane wrote at the daily planet.
My night with Superman.
These are also Easter eggs for the classic
Christopher Reeve movie because they borrowed
a lot from that movie during the Smallville
series.
They have some jokes about him being super huge and buff, because physically he is one
of the largest actors to have played Superman but when they tell him about Lex Luthor.
The reason why he says the president is because remember the Flash Forward in the Smallville
finale was Lex being named president and it was in the year 2018 I believe.
So technically, this is only a couple years
after that because they jumped forward in
time in the Smallville finale.
So technically Lex would be president at this time, but he does say that he gave up his
powers to have a family.
We don't know quite how old his daughters
are, but that's why the kryptonite doesn't
work on when Lex Luthor pulls it out.
They do a little bit of comedy in the tone
of the classic Smallville series when he punches
him out.
still got it.
still stronger.
Then Lois Lane, Erica Durance walks up calls him Smallville like she did on the Smallville
TV show and they go back into the house.
so was a bummer that they de-powered that version of Superman.
I'm sure a whole bunch of people will disagree with their take on that but I'm just happy
that Tom Welling and Erica Durance came back to do this because there were a lot of actors
that said no.
They also try to get Michael Rosenbaum to
come back and guest star but he declined,
but number 5 we go to kingdom come Superman on earth 96
The reason why it's earth 96 is because as
an Easter egg for the kingdom come Comics
that were published in 1996 when Lois Lane walks up to meet him and he recognizes her
evil kind of familiar, they play the lowest
theme song from the classic Christopher Reeves
Superman movie yet to remember that they used all the same John Williams theme songs when
they did Superman returns with Brandon Routh.
Not only is he playing his version of Superman from Superman returns because he references
his son Jason from that movie.
Remember they introduced a version of Superboy, but he's also meant to be an older version
of Christopher Reeves Superman, so it's like saying the Christopher Reeve Superman eventually
became kingdom come Superman, the Easter egg for his origin story and the reason why he
wears that black emblem is right out of the
kingdom come Comics the Joker in those comics
came in.
Gassed the daily planet destroying Lois Lane and a whole bunch of other people.
Number four though Superman versus Superman Lex Luthor shows up with the book of destiny
to force kingdom come Superman to fight Tyler hoechlin's Superman.
The important thing to remember about this fight is that they're doing a live-action
Superman TV show with Tyler Hoechlin's Superman next year.
This fight is a really good example for what
his show will look like when he's flying around
doing the action scenes so it's sort of a
teaser for the Superman TV show.
When they eventually calm him down.
He says this is actually the second time that I've gone crazy and had to fight myself.
That's actually a reference to Superman 3
when he was separated into Clark Kent and
Superman and Superman was super dark.
If you haven't seen that movie in a while
that's from the Superman movie where that
gif comes from of Superman taking the shot at the bar, but number 3.
The older Kevin Conroy Batman from Batman beyond and kingdom come, just goes completely
off the deep end you see all the Easter eggs and his trophies.
There's the Joker playing card.
The snow for Mr. freeze and the broken glasses from his version of Superman that he destroyed.
Who do you think put them in this exoskeleton? they reveal the kryptonite in his exoskeleton,
but they eventually wind up killing him off
saying there's no hope.
He welcomes the antimatter wave there's no more hope for this earth.
Just let it all come and wash it away.
About halfway through his descent into madness.
You could tell when they were taking this
oh he's not going to be the bat of the future
that is the paragon of hope they're going
to make batwoman the paragon of hope and he
bat of the future.
It was really on the nose and super cringey.
I wasn't super happy with the way they did
that, come on this gotta be at least a couple
other alternate Earths with other versions
of Batman that didn't completely go crazy.
The big reason why we probably didn't see
a bunch of other versions of Batman is because
Warner Bros. probably only let them use the Batman character for this brief role here
in technically he never really put the Batman cape and cowl on just sitting on that dummy
and him walking around in the exoskeleton.
It's because of the Batman movie that's coming in 2021 with Robert Pattinson and Matt Reeves.
number 2 though they try to bring back Oliver in a Lazarus pit they go to earth 18 North
Dakota obviously for the Jonah hex Easter
egg.
The reason why think it's earth 18.
It's meant to represent the 1800s in the wild West.
their version of Jonah hex here, though, has not become Jonah hex because he doesn't have
the scar, but Sara gives it to him, you're
probably going to get this eventually anyway
they put Oliver in the pit, but because of
all the antimatter is throwing off Constantine's
magic.
he can't find his soul to bring it back.
So for little while in the next episode he's
going to be this mindless animal till they
can fix it.
Everyone comes back to the waverider, they try to lighten the mood a little bit.
you have those funny scenes with Brandon Routh playing against himself when kingdom come
Superman meets Ray Palmer.
oh, do you also have a gluten allergy.
Then number 1, meet the Anti-Monitor.
they finally reveal him in a version of star
labs, no less.
It's hard to tell which version of star labs
it is. is it from Earth one or some alternate
Earth.
Whole thing withlLyla his episode.
If you are sure why was she was hearing voices and why she slowly started to go crazy in.
the crisis on infinite earths comics the anti-monitor winds of up e cdntrolling her and she winds
up killing the monitor.
I don't know if the gongoing to wind doing
that on the TV show but for a little while
in the Comics, he did control her.
That's why the anti-monitor says come harbinger there's work to be done, s.
Ho he's going to be twisting her to his purpose.
But episode 3 is going to be tomorrow night.
Of course i'll do a video for that.
Let me know if there's any Easter eggs in
the episode that you spotted that I didn't
include in the video.
while you wait for everything.
Click here for my crisis on infinite earths
episode 1 video and click here to rewatch
that wonder woman 1984 trailer of billion
more times.
Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome guys tonight!